The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Let's get started.
Drop date is coming up.
So that you didn't do
very well on the midterm,
and you haven't been
doing your homework,
going to recitation,
I would strongly
consider drop date.
And you can see your
TAs to get some idea
of what your grades
are, and what you're
likely to do if you keep on
giving the same performance
you've had so far.
Now, today, we're going to
switch gears again and cover
the last topic for the course.
For the remainder
of the course, we're
going to talk about probability.
It's one of the most
important subjects in all
of math or computer science.
In fact, I was at a frat
last night for dinner,
and they asked me what my
favorite algorithm was.
And I couldn't really think
about my favorite algorithm
was, but in terms of one of the
most important subjects for you
to know about, after induction,
it's probably probability.
It's really important across
math and computer science.
Most of the upper level courses
you take in computer science
are going to use probability.
They're going to expect
you to know the basics.
For example, when you're
designing algorithms in 006
or 6046, you're going to
be designing in some cases
probabilistic algorithms--
algorithms that flip coins
or generate random
numbers to get the result.
And by using randomness,
they run faster.
If you're doing software
engineering later,
you're going to use
probability when
you analyze system performance
or build hash tables.
Probability is used
in information theory,
in coding theory,
in cryptography.
In fact, our nation's
codes, their security
depends on
probabilistic analysis.
Because the bad guys
are using probabilistic
algorithms to break
the crypto-system.
And we'll give an example of
that in another week or so.
Probability is
obviously important
if you're doing game theory
or if you like to gamble,
really critical in gambling.
In fact, we're going to analyze
a lot of different gambling
games over the next few weeks.
And for fun, we'll
play some in class.
In fact, we'll play
one later today.
And it's amazing how often
the intuition is wrong.
You think the
answer goes one way,
and then it's
actually the other.
Probability is important in
the study of fault tolerance.
For example, how
do you figure out
the probability there's going
to be some critical failure that
causes the space
shuttle to crash?
Or a critical failure that
causes a nuclear plant
to meltdown?
That's done through
probabilistic analysis.
And we'll do some
examples of that.
Probability comes
up in everyday life.
We just had an election.
And running up to
the election, you
get all these polls that
say that's so-and-so
is ahead of so-and-so by three
points with a margin of error
of five points.
So it's a statistical dead
heat, is what they say.
Well, what the heck
does that mean?
In fact, usually they've
got it screwed up.
And we're going to spend
the recitation where you're
going to do a margin of
error analysis for a poll,
and see how many people
do you need to poll to get
a pretty accurate result?
Comes up in the medical studies.
Does cholesterol
cause heart disease?
Does smoking cause lung cancer?
How effective is a certain drug?
Say you get tested for a disease
and it comes back positive.
Well, there's false positives
and false negatives.
What are the chances you
really have the disease?
So the list goes on and on.
In fact, we're going to
see all these examples.
We've got eight lectures
and eight recitations.
And there's just no end
of interesting examples
where probability
comes into play.
The bad news is,
probability is probably
the most misunderstood
subject in all of mathematics
and the sciences.
In fact, Mark Twain
once said, there's
three kinds of lies-- lies,
damned lies, and statistics,
meaning probability.
Because it's so easy
to lie with statistics.
And we're going to see lots
and lots of examples of that.
In fact, newspaper
articles, you know,
have all sorts of things that
are just horribly fallacious
based on statistics.
And we'll see examples.
In fact, we're going to even
debunk a very famous article--
published research paper--
by some famous computer
scientists at Berkeley.
Where they got to a conclusion
using a very standard method
you see all the time--
completely fallacious.
And we'll see that.
So you can think of that
as, I'm going to teach you
how to lie with statistics.
Even better, how not to be taken
in by incorrect arguments using
probability theory.
Now, at MIT, it's
probably the subject
that most often
trips up students
in their PhD qualifying exams.
You know, there's no
better way to strike
terror in the heart of a
student then to be sitting there
and ask them a
question while they're
at the board, what's the
probability that foo happens?
It's like panic sets
in when they've got
to do a probabilistic analysis.
And now, MIT PhD
students are good.
You know, they can crank out
the most horrendous calculation,
no problem, come up with really
clever ideas to solve problems.
But you get into probability,
it gets into trouble.
In fact, even the other
faculty sitting there
start squirming around when
this question's being posed.
You know, and probability
questions are--
and we'll see some
examples today-- are always
the best at faculty
parties, just
can ruin people's whole night.
You know, what's the
probability this happens?
And it's some weird answer.
Now, the strange thing
about this-- well,
first strange thing is that our
human intuition is terrible.
And you will see that.
Your intuition will
be wrong, just the way
our brains are
created genetically.
But the good news is that
probability can be very simple.
If you force yourself to just go
to the basic principles-- which
we're going to cover-- and
go through the basic template
of how to solve a problem--
which we're going to cover--
it is easy, and
you can't go wrong.
The key is forcing yourself
to just actually write it
down, follow the
basic principles,
and get to the answer.
As opposed to saying, oh, the
answer's that and here's why.
Because it's amazing how
often you'll be wrong if
you just try to rely
on your intuition.
Now, we're going to start
today our study of probability
with a famous, simple game.
And the game is known as
the Monty Hall problem.
Now, do you all know
who Monty Hall was?
You're probably too young.
Yeah, OK, not many people
know who Monte Hall was.
But back in the 1970s, there
was a very popular daytime TV
show-- a game show--
called Let's Make a Deal.
And it was a great show.
It was the precursor
of Wheel of Fortune--
if you're old enough to
have seen that-- and then
Deal or No Deal after that.
There's always some game
show that's really popular.
Anyway, back in the '70s,
it was Let's Make a Deal,
and Monty Hall was the host.
How many people have ever
heard of Let's Make a Deal?
Raise your hand if you've
ever heard of that.
OK, so it still has some fame.
Good.
All right.
Now, Monty Hall, of
course, was the precursor
of Pat Sajak of Wheel of
Fortune and Howie Mandel,
you know, from Deal or No Deal.
And his assistant
was Carol Merrill.
She was also famous as
the beautiful assistant.
Now, in Let's Make a
Deal, they TV audience
would come dressed
up in wild costumes.
And Monty would go
into the audience
and pick out a contestant
from the audience based
on how wild their
costume was-- you know,
somebody that would
look interesting for TV.
And what he would do is he'd
buy a piece of the costume--
maybe their hat or
shirt or something--
and give them $100 for a
piece of their costume.
And then he would say,
hey look, you know,
if you give me back the
$100 I just gave you,
I'm going to let you have
your choice of what's
behind door number one,
door number two, or door
number three.
Or sometimes it would be box
number one, box number two,
and box number three.
Now, because people have
seen the game show before,
they knew that behind
one of the doors
was a brand new car or
underneath one of the boxes
was a diamond ring.
And behind the other doors
were goats or donkeys
or something totally useless.
So one of the three
doors has a big prize,
the other two got nothing.
But because anybody would pay
$100 for a one-in-three chance
at the car, they played.
And they're on national TV.
So they give the $100 back to
Monty, and they pick a door,
say door number one.
Monty wouldn't open door
number one right away.
What he would do is say, OK,
you're sure you like that?
All right.
Carol, can you
please reveal what's
behind door number three?
So Carol opens up
door number three,
and there's one of the
donkeys sitting there
or a goat sitting there.
Well, now there's
only two doors left.
One of them has the car.
So he'd ask the contestant,
well, you've seen the goat.
There's a car behind
one of the two doors.
Do you want to stick
with door number one?
Or do you want to switch
and get door number two?
And then the audience is
screaming, you know, switch,
stick, you know, door
number one, door number two.
You know, the guy's
wife's there screaming
at him and everything.
You know, he's got to
pick, so he picks one.
And you know, if he picks the
car, well, his wife's thrilled.
They live happily ever.
He's a hero on national TV.
And if he picks the goat, you
know, he's looking at a divorce
and his career's ruined.
So it's pretty important that
he gets the right strategy here.
Now, the question we're
going to look at today
is whether or not
the contestant should
switch, playing this game.
Now, before we do
the analysis, we're
going to actually play
the game in class.
I've got three boxes here.
The game we're going to
play is the same idea.
The prizes are a
little different.
Instead of a diamond
ring or a brand new car,
we've got $10 Toski's
gift certificates.
You know, your tuition
only goes so far here.
Instead of donkeys
or goats, we've
got something much better, the
ever-popular nerd pride pocket
protector.
And just to be
clear, this is not
the prize, the gift
certificate here--
this is much, much better.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
Now, in terms of Monty
Hall, we don't have him,
but you have me.
But I am very happy to report
that we're bringing Carol
Merrill out of retirement.
She's coming and making a
special appearance today,
I hope, at 6042.
Do we have Carol?
GUEST SPEAKER: Hi, Tom.
PROFESSOR: Oh,
yes, we have Carol.
That's scary.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
Oh, Jesus.
OK.
[APPLAUSE]
As you can see, the years
have not been kind to Carol.
And your tuition only
does goes so far.
Now, we need three volunteers.
We're going to play
the game three times.
All right, got a couple there.
Why don't you come down?
We've got three volunteers here.
All right, we'll get
the boxes set up.
And Carol, why don't
you set those up
and load them up with-- these
are the gift certificates.
That's the pocket
protector there.
All right, now, don't look.
You've got to get back over
there so you can't see--
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
And no, no, no, now, you've
got the film going, you know,
here we go.
All right.
So Carol is going to put the
prize in one of the boxes
and the pocket
protectors in the other.
Now, I want you all to
be thinking, you know,
what's the right strategy here?
Is it better to switch?
Does it matter?
What are the chances of winning?
One in three?
One in two?
All right, so who's our
first volunteer here?
All right, come on over.
We're going to write
your name on the board
because we're going to keep
track of what happens here.
What's your name?
TERRANCE: Terrance.
PROFESSOR: Terrance.
All right.
Now, first thing
you've got to do,
Terrance, is pick a box as
your basic choice to start.
TERRANCE: Two.
PROFESSOR: Number two, OK.
All right, you
picked number two.
Hm, interesting choice.
Now, Carol, can you show
him one of the other boxes?
All right, which on was
that you showed there?
You revealed number three.
And what was under number three?
AUDIENCE: Pocket protector.
PROFESSOR: Pocket protector.
Oh, God, you may never
live this down, Carol.
OK.
Now, Terrance, as you
know, one of these
has the gift certificate.
One of them has another
pocket protector.
And now, you've got
to decide, are you
going to stick with number two,
or are you going to switch?
In fact, class,
you know, Terrance
may need some help
here, figuring this out,
so what do you recommend?
[AUDIENCE  CHATTER]
TERRANCE: I'll switch.
PROFESSOR: He is
going to switch.
All right, and Carol,
can you reveal his prize?
What did you get?
Ah, he gets the prize.
So he wins.
Very nice, OK.
So you get $10 at Tosci's.
Well done.
Who's next?
What's your name?
CHINUA: Chinua.
PROFESSOR: Chinua.
How do I spell that?
CHINUA: Chin-U-A.
PROFESSOR: All right, easy.
OK.
Now, Chinua, which-- have we
got new prizes loaded in there?
All right.
Now, it may not be
the same as last time.
OK.
What box do you like?
CHINUA: Number three.
PROFESSOR: Number three.
Which one is number three?
Is that the one close to me?
Yeah, that is.
OK.
Number three.
All right, Carol, can you show
him one of the other boxes,
please?
Carol shows you number two.
All right, Chinua,
what do you think?
Do you want to stick or switch?
Do you want to stick with
three or switch to one?
One had it last time, right?
[AUDIENCE CHATTER]
CHINUA: Switch.
PROFESSOR: He's going to switch.
OK, so that means you
are picking number one.
Carol, can you show
him what he's won?
Another gift certificate.
All right, now, Carol it is
OK to use a different box
for the gift certificate.
[LAUGHTER]
We can move them around.
All right, who's
our last contestant?
What's your name?
TY: Ty.
PROFESSOR: T-Y, OK.
That's good.
Oh, yeah, yeah, turn around.
No peeking here.
OK.
Ty, what's your first choice?
TY: One.
PROFESSOR: Box number one.
Yeah, that's been the one with
the gift certificate, for sure.
Carol, can you show
him another box?
Way too many cameras
in this room.
This is not good for Carol.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, Carol has revealed
box number two.
[AUDIENCE CHATTER]
Switch has worked
twice in a row.
AUDIENCE: Now you gotta stay.
AUDIENCE: Take them both.
PROFESSOR: Just one.
AUDIENCE: Well, if you switch,
there's two-thirds chance
of winning, and they
already won so--
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Oh, getting
some theory here now.
What do you think, Ty?
Switch.
All right.
What happened?
What do you know?
All right, now,
gentlemen, I'd like
you to explain why-- each
in turn, why did you switch?
TERRANCE: I switched-- it
seemed like the majority vote.
PROFESSOR: The
majority knew what
they were talking about, OK.
You have faith in
these guys, huh?
All right.
How about you, Chinua,
why did you switch?
CHINUA: Um, I was
told that it's more
likely to be if you switch.
PROFESSOR: And you believe
what you hear, huh?
[LAUGHTER]
TY: I don't know who said
it, but it sounded good.
PROFESSOR: Sounded good
Yeah, that two-thirds thing.
Well, as you can see,
you're guaranteed
to win if you switch, right?
[LAUGHTER]
All right, Thank you very much.
Enjoy the ice cream.
OK.
So how many people think
it helps to switch?
Raise your hand if you
think it helps to switch.
How many people think it
does not help to switch?
Raise your hand.
Anybody?
Oh, everybody likes
the switch thing here.
Does this data help you decide?
No.
Anything could have
happened with three trials.
In fact, we'll talk about
statistical inference
and statistical sampling later.
If you switch, what do you
think the odds of winning are?
AUDIENCE: 100%
PROFESSOR: 100%?
OK, who likes 100%?
Raise your hand.
Well, we've got a couple.
How many people think
it's 50-50 if you switch?
Yeah, a lot.
How many people think it's
worse than 50-50 if you switch?
Not many.
How many people think
it's better than 50-50?
Ah, that's I think most of
you there, pretty close.
All right, now, the
answers to these questions
are very easy to work out--
and we're going to do it.
We're going to figure out
the probability exactly--
if you use mathematics.
But it's really
tricky if you try
to use intuition or
hand waving arguments.
Now, for example,
this game-- Carol
wants to leave-- yeah, Carol,
let's give Carol a hand here.
She did a wonderful job.
Well done.
[APPLAUSE]
Yikes.
I'm going to get in
trouble here, too, now.
You know?
OK.
For example, this game, and
this particular version of it,
was the subject of a series of
articles in Parade Magazine.
This is an old version
of Parade Magazine.
And what I'm going to do is
hand out the series of articles.
And the TAs are going to
help me hand these out.
There was three of them with
a lot of write-ins here.
I'm going to give
you a bundle here.
There you go.
I'll give the rest to Oscar.
Great.
Now, Marilyn has a column
every week in Parade.
And people write in
questions, usually
about their love life
and weird things.
And she answers them.
And she's well
qualified to do this
because she's listed in the
Guinness Book of World Records
as having the highest IQ of
a human being ever, at 228.
And so, you know
she's in some sense
qualified to answer any
question that is written in.
Now, in September of 1990-- and
we're passing out the articles
now and it shows
the first article--
this guy named Craig
Whitaker writes in and asks
Marilyn if you should
switch in this game.
So you can all read that.
It says, suppose you're on
a game show and you're given
the choice of three doors.
Behind one door is a car.
Behind the others, goats.
You pick a door, say
number one, and the host,
who knows what's
behind the doors,
opens another one, say door
three, which has a goat.
He says to you, do you want
to pick door number two?
Is it to your
advantage to switch?
Now, Marilyn writes back
saying, very plainly,
yes, you should switch.
The first door had a
one-in-three chance of winning.
The second door has a
two-in-three chance.
Here's a good way to
visualize what's going on.
Suppose there are
a million doors.
You pick door number one.
Then the host, who knows
what's behind the doors,
reveals every other door
but one and 777,777.
Well, it would sort
of look like 777,777
is the one with the car, and
you'd switch pretty fast.
All right that's her argument.
That is not exactly a
proof, OK, that the answer
is you should switch or
that the probability is 2/3.
All right?
Now, because she's
giving another problem
with a million doors, but you've
got a problem with three doors.
And as we'll see in recitation
tomorrow, the number of doors
actually matters in terms
of some strategies here.
So people weren't
convinced by this.
And so, if you look
to the next page,
you see people writing in.
And there's a lot a write-ins.
The first one's by Robert
Sachs, who's actually--
I looked him up on
Google, and he's
on the faculty at
George Mason University.
I also noticed that
in his history,
he got his BA from Harvard.
So that should tell you
something about the quality
of his response here.
He says, since you seem to enjoy
coming straight to the point,
I'll do the same.
You blew it.
Let me explain.
If one door is
shown to be a loser,
that information
changes the probability
of either remaining
choice, neither of which
has any reason to
be more likely.
And so, the answer is one
half of having the car.
Then he says, as a
professional mathematician,
I'm very concerned with
the general public's
lack of mathematical skills.
Please help by
confessing your error.
And in the future,
be more careful.
Just a little gratuitous
extra statement there.
Next we've got a PhD from
Florida, Scott Smith, who says,
you blew it, and
you blew it big.
Since you seem to
have difficulty
grasping the basic principles
at work here, I'll explain.
After the host reveals
a goat, you now
have a one-in-two
chance of being correct.
Whether you change
your selection or not,
the odds are the same.
There is enough mathematical
illiteracy in this country,
and we don't need the world's
highest IQ propagating more.
Shame.
Well, now, this guy is
right about that one point
about mathematical
illiteracy in the country.
The next guy, Barry
Pasternack, you know,
he lists himself as California
Faculty Association.
He actually was president of the
California Faculty Association.
He says, your answer to
the question is an error,
but if it's any constellation,
many of my academic colleagues
have also been stumped
by this problem.
OK.
So next page,
Marilyn writes back.
And she says, you
know, good heavens,
with so much learned
opposition, I'll
bet this is going to keep math
classes all over the country
busy on Monday.
And it did.
It was a huge uproar
at the time about this.
So now she tries
to explain it some
more with shells and stuff
under the shells and so forth,
trying to argue it.
And then she says, just try
the experiment six times
or something, and you'll see.
You know, but, it's
not really convincing.
It's not a proof.
She's sort of waving hands at
it to give you some idea of why
she thinks she's right.
But when I look at
the hand waving here
versus the hand waving
on those faculty,
well, it's all hand waving.
All right.
So you go to the next
page, and now the letters
are getting a little nastier.
We got another University
of Florida guy.
He says, may I suggest
you obtain and refer
to a standard textbook
on probability
before you try to answer a
question of this type again.
Then Robert Smith,
Georgia State,
I am sure you will
receive many letters
on this topic from high
school and college students.
Perhaps you should keep
a few addresses for help
with future columns.
These are great.
Now this next guy, Ray
Bobo, now, he's a real guy.
I looked him up, too.
It's not fake.
That's his real name.
And I've got to say,
if my name was Bobo,
I'd think twice before
writing into Parade Magazine,
you know, especially
if I'm wrong.
Anyway, here's Bobo.
You are utterly incorrect
about the game show question.
And I hope this controversy
will call some public attention
to the serious national crisis
in mathematical education.
Well, that's fair.
If you could admit
your error, you
will have contributed
constructively
towards a solution of
a deplorable situation.
Now, here's [INAUDIBLE].
How many irate
mathematicians are needed
to get you to change your mind?
Well that's proof by
intimidation, right?
[LAUGHTER]
You know, it's not,
here's the reason why.
It's just, so many irate
mathematicians said
it, they must, must be right.
Now the next guy.
I am in shock that
after being corrected
by at least three
mathematicians,
you still did not
see your mistake.
As if three
mathematicians, that's
sort of the criteria
for correctness.
Oh, this guy is bad.
Maybe women look at math
problems differently than men.
Ooh.
Well, maybe it's a good
thing in this case.
I don't know.
Oh, then we have Glen
Calkins, you are the goat.
Finally, this guy, US
Army Research Institute,
a little scary.
you made a mistake, but
look at the positive side.
If all those PhD's
were wrong, the country
would be in some
very serious trouble.
All right.
Now Marilyn writes an
even longer response
because she's getting zillions
of letters, 90% voting
against her, that she's wrong.
She begins now, suggests
a nationwide experiment,
so that, nationwide, you'd
do the sample a million times
and get the answer, which
really wouldn't prove it either.
Then we go to the last page.
There's one last letter.
And this is what finished
the controversy in the press.
Comes from MIT.
You are indeed correct.
My colleagues at work had
a ball with this problem,
and I dare say that most of
them, including me at first,
thought you were wrong.
So maybe that $50,000 a year
somebody's paying for education
is worth something, because MIT
came in and agreed with her.
OK.
It turns out that Marilyn
was correct in her statement
that you should switch.
And if you switch, you have
a 2/3 chance of winning.
So if you don't switch, you've
got a 1/3 chance of winning,
provided that
Monty is guaranteed
to open a door with goat.
You know and that's
the assumption here.
And the proof is simple.
Although Marilyn's reasoning
wasn't so convincing,
I didn't think.
And all those PhDs that wrote
in with those stupid letters,
they're probably
intelligent people.
After all, they got advanced
degrees in mathematics,
and most of them were
faculty teaching mathematics.
A little scary.
But they just weren't
following the basic principles.
They were following
their intuition.
They didn't go through
the basic steps
to figure out the probability.
So that's what
we're going to do.
We're going to go
through the basic steps
now and see how to solve it.
And we will use these
steps to solve pretty much
every problem in probability.
OK?
So the key, the first step,
is to look at the sample
space of possible outcomes.
Let me define sample
space and outcome.
The sample space for an
experiment, or a probability
game-- you can treat this Monty
Hall game as an experiment--
is simply the set of
all possible outcomes,
things that could happen.
In fact, let me
define an outcome,
also known as an atomic
event or a sample point.
An outcome, also
known as a sample
point-- we'll use those
terms interchangeably--
consists of all the information
about the experiment,
including-- and
that's after it's
been performed-- including the
values of all random choices.
For example, say we want to
know the probability of winning
in Monty Hall if you switch.
All right, let's
figure that out.
So in that case, we're going to
define an outcome of the Monty
Hall game or a sample point--
and I'm assuming in this case,
we know you're going to switch
and the contestant switches--
consists of three things.
First, the box with the prize,
where did Carroll put it?
Second, the box chosen
by the contestant.
And third, the box
that was revealed.
Once you know
those three things,
you know everything
about what happened.
All right?
For example, let's look
at a typical sample point.
Say I took sample point,
or outcome, 2,1,3.
This is the outcome where
the prize is the box 2.
The player picks first box 1.
And Carol reveals box 3.
OK, now in this case,
in this outcome,
did the contestant win?
Yes, because we're
assuming-- for henceforth,
for most of the rest
of the day, we're
assuming the switch
case, because we're
going to analyze that.
So that's fixed, they switch.
They come in knowing
they're going to switch.
So the prize is in 2, all right?
The prize is here.
The player started here.
Carol revealed 3.
And when they switched,
they got the prize.
So in this outcome,
the player won.
OK.
Now, does every 3-tuple here
correspond to a sample point,
to our possible outcome?
No.
What's an example of a sample
point with numbers 1, 2,
and 3 that's not.
Yeah?
Very good.
Yeah, so for example, 1,
2, 1 is not a sample point,
is not in the set,
the sample space,
because we can't reveal
the box with the prize.
Similarly, 2, 1, 1 is
not a sample point,
because we can't reveal the
box that the player picked.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE : I think the first two
pieces of data actually define
the third one, because
once, or-- actually, no,
if they're the same.
PROFESSOR: Right,
so if the player
picked the box with
the prize, which
never happened in our case.
For example, 1, 1 2 and
1, 1, 3 are both possible
because you could put the prize
here, the player could pick it,
now Carol has a choice
of revealing 2 or 3.
OK?
So these are OK.
All right, so let's figure out
a nice way of characterizing
all outcomes in
the sample space.
Now, to do this, we're
going to set up a tree.
And we're going to use
a thing called the tree
method to construct
the sample space,
getting all the outcomes.
All right.
So the first thing we do is
figure out where the prize is.
And we'll represent that as
sort of like a decision tree.
There's three choices.
It's in box 1, box 2, or box 3.
Then the next thing is the
box that the player picked.
And we'll continue our
decision tree here.
Each of these now
has three branches.
And they're labeled 1, 2, or 3.
And then, the last step
is which box is revealed.
Now, in this case, if
the prize is in one
and the player chose one,
there's two possibilities.
We could reveal 2 or reveal 3.
So we get 1, 2, 3
here and 1, 2, 3 here.
What about here?
Prize is in box 1, box
2 is revealed-- sorry,
player picked box 2.
Prize is in 1, player picks
2, how many choices for which
box is revealed?
One.
And which box is
going to be revealed?
3.
All right, this is
sample point 1, 2, 3.
And here we've got 1,
3, 2 is the only choice.
All right.
And let's do--
maybe I'll, we ought
to fill the whole
thing out here.
2, 1, 3-- I'm going to run out
of space, but-- 2, 2, now this
splits into 1 and 3.
All right?
So we have here
2, 2, 1, 2, 2, 3.
Now let me do the last
one, 2, 3, 1 here.
And now I'll bring
these up over here.
I've got 3, 1, 2.
Then I've got 3, 2, 1.
And finally, I've got 3, 3
with two choices, 1 and 2.
All right?
That is now the construction
of the entire sample space,
all the possible outcomes.
How many sample
points are there here?
How many possible outcomes?
AUDIENCE : 12
PROFESSOR: 12.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10, 11, 12, OK.
Let's see which ones correspond
to victory for the player.
Let's label each one
as a win for the player
or a loss for the player.
What's this one?
Yeah.
Prize is in 1,
the player chose 1
where the prize was, and
then switched away from it.
Loss.
What about this one?
Loss, same reason.
That's a win.
The prize is here, the player
went there and switched,
so they wound up there.
Win.
And these are all wins
for the same reason.
Whoop, not this one.
2, 1, 1, the player got
it right to start with,
and then switched away.
That's a loss.
Loss.
Win, win, win.
And here the player got it
right, they switched away,
it's a lose.
All right, so we've
labeled every outcome
as to whether the player
who's switching wins or loses.
How many sample points
lead to victory?
6.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 out of 12.
Uh-oh.
Was Marilyn wrong?
Is it really Bobo was right?
It's 50-50?
Half the sample points
lead to victory.
Hm, what's missing here?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE : The first
two are identical,
the box with the prize
and the box chosen first.
Each of those two sample
points coming from that
are half as likely as
the single sample points.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
What we're missing
here is the likelihood
of an outcome, the probability
that this is what happens.
We're missing one more thing.
And this is really
critical when you're
making your sample spaces.
You need to make sure you get
the probabilities assigned
to each event.
They're not necessarily
equally likely.
In fact, what we need to do is
to construct the probability
space.
So lets define that.
Your probability space consists
of a sample space-- which
we've already talked about.
That's just all these outcomes--
and a probability function
that maps-- and we call
this function, usually, PR.
We'll have, sometimes it'll
be f or something like that--
but PR maps the sample
space, S, to the real numbers
such that first, for every
outcome in the sample space,
the probability is between
0 and 1 of that outcome.
And 2, if you sum
up the probabilities
of all the outcomes, you get 1.
So the sum over all outcomes of
the probability of the outcome
is 1.
All right?
So the sample space
is all the outcomes.
The probability space adds
in-- has this extra thing--
the probability of each outcome.
And really, it
could be anything,
as long is the probability
of every outcome
is between 0 and 1 and
they all add up to 1.
That's it.
All right.
Now, there's a
natural interpretation
of what the probability
function is.
And that is the probability
of a sample point,
well, should be the
probability of its outcome.
And this is sort of where you
get the to Marilyn saying,
hey, try it a million times
and you'll see 2/3 of the time,
roughly, you get the
right, that you win.
So for every outcome,
the probability
of that outcome,
that real number,
should be the probability that
when you run the experiment,
w is what happens.
w will be the outcome.
In other words, if
probability of w
were a half, what
that means is you
should get that half the
time, roughly speaking.
We'll get into really
details of that later.
In other words, you toss
a fair coin, you flip it.
Well, you might say, a
probability half of a heads.
All right?
And so, this function, then,
the probability of heads is 1/2.
Now, assigning the right
probabilities to the outcomes
is 95% of the work.
In fact, if you
screw that up, you're
doomed because you can't
get the right answer.
So for example, if we just
said, OK, each of these
is probability 1/12,
we'd get Bobo's answer
as the probability of winning.
So that's not too good.
Now, to get the right
probabilities for the Monty
Hall problem, we have to
make some assumptions.
So let's write those down.
So the first assumption
we're going to make
is that Carol put the
prize in a random box.
They're all equally likely.
So the prize is in each
box with probability 1/3.
The next assumption
we're going to make
is that the player didn't
see which box has the prize.
OK?
In other words, and
more specifically,
no matter where the
prize is, the player
picks each box with
probability of 1/3.
So the player's making,
effectively, a random choice.
All right, and there's one more
assumption we're going to make.
Anybody have any
ideas about what's
left to make as an
assumption here?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE : I guess, if
Carol's the one who's opening
the boxes, she knows
where all the prizes are.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK.
So what assumption
should I make?
Yeah, that she picks a box at
random if she has a choice.
All right, so we're going
to make that assumption.
So that no matter
where the prize
is, if Carol has a
choice, she picks
each box with probability 1/2.
Now, why is this
third one important?
Why might that really matter?
Can anybody think of a reason
why that could be relevant?
What if Carol had
some strategy in mind
that the contestant knew about?
Can you think of why
that might be useful.
AUDIENCE : If the contestant
were able to produce
information based off of that,
then there's a higher chance
a contestant could figure
out which one to choose.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
In fact, several years
ago, when I was lecturing,
I said, in fact it
could make a difference.
That there is a way that
Carol can convey information
to the player by of two she's
choosing, which one to pick.
Like, if she has a
choice of 2 or 3,
say she always
picks bigger one, 3.
Well, that might tell
you information about,
she didn't pick 2, so
maybe it has to have,
or she-- well, I don't know.
In fact, that's
wrong, and it doesn't
matter in the case of 2
boxes, this assumption.
We're going to make
it, because we're going
to do the analysis with it.
But for three boxes, you can
show that it really doesn't
matter for this assumption.
But if you go to
four boxes, it does.
And so in recitation
tomorrow, you're
going to consider the four
box version of this game.
And if Carol has a strategy
that the player knows about,
you could improve the
player's chances of winning.
But not for three, it turns out.
In any case, when you're
setting up a problem,
you've got to set
up your assumptions.
Otherwise, you
don't get anywhere.
These are sort of like
axioms, same kind of thing.
It's fine to make assumptions.
Just state what they are.
Now, of course, you also
want them to be reasonable.
All right.
So maybe we're going to
go back now and figure out
how to get the
probabilities of the sample
points, or the outcomes,
for Monty Hall.
Let's go do that.
And maybe I'll draw them
in a different color here.
What I'm going to do
is label every edge
with a probability associated
with taking that step.
So if the prize is placed in
each box with a probability
of 1/3, that says this happens
with probability 1/3, that's
1/3, and that's 1/3.
Same thing here.
Assumption two says
that no matter where
the prize is, say it's in box
1, the player chooses each box
with a probably of 1/3.
So given that the
prize is in box 1,
the player chooses 1 with
1/3, 2 with 1/3, 3 with 1/3.
Same if the prize is in box 2.
So I label every edge
here with the probability.
All right.
Now I go to this level.
And I'm, at this node, I'm
in the state where prize
is in box 1, player
selected box 1,
so Carol has a choice
of 2 or 3 to reveal.
And she's going to reveal
each one with probability 1/2.
So I label 1/2 on each
of these, because that's
what we've assumed.
What probability do I
put on this edge here?
Probability 1, because
there's no choice.
Carol has to do it.
The same here.
And I get 1/2, 1/2,
1, 1, 1, 1/2, 1/2.
All right, so I've labeled
every edge with its probability.
Pretty simple, because
it was all assumed.
Now I've got to get a
probability for each outcome.
And we do that with
the following rule.
The probability
of a sample point
is the product of
the probabilities
on the path leading
to the outcome,
the path in the tree leading
to the outcome or the sample
point.
OK.
So what this says is just
really, really simple.
The probability of this sample
point is 1/3 times 1/3 times
1/2, 1/18.
The probability of this sample
point is 1/3 times 1/3 times
1/2, 1/18.
What's the probability of this
sample point going to be here?
1/9.
I've got 1/3 times 1/3 times,
well, this g was 1, is 1/9.
The next one here is 1/3
times 1/3 times 1, 1/9.
Same thing here.
1/3 times 1/3 times 1 is 1/9.
Then I get 1/3 times
1/3 times 1/2 for 1/18.
And I can keep on going.
This would be 1/9.
This one has a 1, so it's a 1/9.
An 1/18 and 1/18.
OK.
Now, that's the rule.
And you'll always do this.
You can sort of
see why it works.
You'll understand
after another week why,
for sure, why it works.
But intuitively, you know,
to get to this outcome,
these are the choices
we had to make.
First, the box
had to be-- sorry,
the prize had to be in box 1.
There's a one-in-three
chance of that happening.
Now, in those
one-out-of-three chances,
the chance the player
also picked box 1,
1/3 of the time of 1/3
of the time that happens.
All right?
1/3 of the time, you're here.
And of that, 1/3 of those
times, you get to here.
That's 1/3 times 1/3, or 1/9.
And then, 1/2 of those times,
Carol happen to reveal box 2.
That's 1/18.
So do you see why
that might make sense,
why you're multiplying these?
Because at every step, you
have a chance to diverge.
And the probability
you take the step
that we're following
here-- say, in this case,
it was 1/2-- that cuts down
the chance you land here
by that probability, 1/2.
Any questions about that?
All right.
For now, you can
take it on faith.
We'll see why after we
do a few more of these
over the next week or so.
Any questions there?
Is that OK?
OK.
Oh, yeah, all right?
AUDIENCE : [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: On this one?
Only one choice.
So it happens with
probability 1.
Any other questions?
OK.
All right.
So now we can figure out
the probability of winning.
Well, the probability of
winning is we have 1/9, 1/9,
there's 3 of them,
4 of them, 5, 6.
All right?
So the probability of
winning here is 6 times 1/9.
Because you just sum up the
probabilities of the winning
sample points.
There's six of winning.
They're each 1/9.
And that's 2/3.
OK?
So Marilyn was right.
There's a 2/3 chance of
winning if you switch.
And now, this is
a formal argument
that gives you that answer.
The nice thing is it works
for pretty much every problem
you ever think about.
Now, in general,
if you want to know
the probability
of any event, you
can follow this same method.
Let me define what an event is.
An event is simply a
subset of outcomes,
a subset of the sample space.
For example, we could
define the event of losing.
Let's call EL, E sub-L, to be
the event that player loses,
the player loses, with
the switch strategy.
All right?
Now, to compute the
probability of an event,
we just add the probabilities
of the outcomes in that set.
So let's get that down.
All right, so formally,
the probability
that an event occurs is simply
the sum, we'll call an event,
e, let's say, event, e.
It's a subset of
the sample space.
The probability that
e occurs is the sum
over the sample points in e of
the probability of those sample
points.
So for example, the
probability of the event, EL,
where the player
loses, well, there's
six sample points
where the player loses,
each with the probability 1/18.
So it's 1/3 is the probability
the player loses on the switch
strategy.
And that's not surprising
because you either win
or you lose.
The probabilities
have to add to 1.
So if won with probability 2/3,
you lose with probability 1/3.
OK?
All right.
So Marilyn was right,
much better to switch.
We'll do a bunch more examples
with Monty Hall tomorrow.
Are there any other questions
on Monty Hall before I change
gears?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you showed
that when you switch,
you are more likely
to win than to lose.
But you didn't show that
that's not also true
when you don't switch.
PROFESSOR: Ah good question.
What happens if you're
playing the stay strategy.
Right, maybe you win 2/3
of the time when you stay.
Maybe.
Maybe not.
Right?
Because if I win
when I switch, what
would have happened
if I'd stayed?
I'd have lost.
Because if I win
when I switch, it
means the prize is over there.
So if I stay, I'm going to lose.
Which means that if I
do the stay strategy,
I'm going to lose
2/3 of the time.
So you're right.
I didn't cover that.
But we can.
It's not too hard in this
case because the probability
of winning on a switch
equals the probability
of losing on a stick.
So the probability that
you win with switch
equals the probability you
lose with a stick strategy.
All right?
And they're both 2/3,
because they're the same
and this is 2/3.
So in fact, what's,
then, the chance
you win with a stick strategy?
1/3.
And that's sort of you know,
where Marilyn was coming from.
Because she said, well,
if you pick the box right
the first time, which
is what you need
to get to win with
a stick strategy,
the chance you pick the
right box is one-in-three.
And showing, you know, a
goat over here didn't matter.
It's still one-in-three.
Now that's gets a--
that's intuition,
but it can get you
trouble, because say
you picked this box and Carol
showed you both of these boxes,
and they had pocket protectors.
Then what do you know
about the probability
you won with a stick?
It's 1.
Ooh, so things did change there.
All right?
So you have to be a little
careful about how you reason,
OK?
You've got to do this.
Stay with that and you'll always
be fine for your strategy.
So really the key is to
resist the temptation
to just sort of use your
intuition to think about it.
All right.
Now, this is a pretty
simple example.
So now I'm going
to do one that's
a little more interesting and a
little more devious in a sense.
So I need a volunteer.
We're going to do
a gambling game.
So I need a volunteer.
All right.
Now, he's raised his
hands before I even
said what the criteria are.
First, you gotta be confident
you understand probability.
Well, you can fake it.
But second, and more
importantly, you've
got to have some money in
your product or you've got
to borrow some on the way down.
You got a few bucks there?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: All
right, come on down.
That's really all that
matters, you know.
OK, now, in this game,
there's three dice.
Well, that's 'cause
you're smart.
OK, so let me show you
the dice in this game.
And these, of course,
are not normal dice.
All right?
So dice A has a 2, a
6, and a 7, and they're
the same on the reverse side.
So it's a six-sided
die, and it's fair.
When you roll it,
the probability A
comes up 2 is going to be 1/3.
All right?
Same for 6 and for 7.
Ah, we're just getting started.
Dice B has a 1, 5, and a 9 and
dice C has a 3, 4, and an 8.
So I got-- they're
all different numbers,
the numbers from 1 to 9.
So just so we're really
clear, the probability
that A comes up 3 is 1/3.
The same for the probability
A comes up 6 is 1/3 and so on.
Ah, yes I do mean 2.
Good.
All right, good, you're
paying attention.
That's good.
There's some hope.
All right?
Now, here's the game.
We're each going to pick a die.
And we're going to roll our die.
And the higher die wins.
We're going to roll them once.
The higher one wins.
And the loser pays
the winner $1.
And no tears, OK?
You got that?
That's good.
He's already trying to
figure out which one to pick.
So let's put your
dollar on the table.
Here we go.
AUDIENCE: I have a $5.
Do you have change?
PROFESSOR: I might have change.
All right.
Let's see here.
Yes, I do have change.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I
do have a dollar.
PROFESSOR: You have a dollar.
All right.
Well, for now anyway.
Let's put the dollar
there on the table.
AUDIENCE: It's going
to be a $20 next.
PROFESSOR: We're just
getting warmed up here.
OK, now, there is-- what's
your name, by the way?
AUDIENCE: Will.
PROFESSOR: Will.
OK, nice to meet you, Will.
There we go.
All right.
Now, there is one problem here.
I don't really have those dice.
So we're going to have to
do a mathematical version
of this bet.
AUDIENCE: You're always
going to win, then.
PROFESSOR: So what
we're going to do
is pretend that we did
a roll, head-to-head,
and whichever one is
more likely to win,
we're going to assume the roll
came out that way, all right?
Now, I know you've been
studying those three guys there,
those three dice.
I'm going to be fair and let you
pick first which one you like.
Now, as you look at
this, you know, you guys
can help him out here if you
can figure out which one's best.
This has got a couple
good sized numbers.
You know, two of
these beat these.
This has the biggest number,
but it also has the smallest.
This has two small guys in it.
You now and you want to pick
the one that's likely to--
AUDIENCE: They all add
up to the same thing.
PROFESSOR: They do all add up
to the same thing, that's true.
Yeah.
Which one do you want?
Which one do you want here Will?
What's your best one there?
A does look pretty good.
You've got two
solid numbers there.
It does.
A looks like it beats
up on C pretty good.
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
I think I'm going
to lose a dollar.
PROFESSOR: That's probably true.
[LAUGHTER]
[AUDIENCE CHATTER]
I don't know.
A looks pretty good to us.
Which one do you like here?
We'll try them out.
We'll play more games here.
A. All right, Will
likes A. All right.
And I'm going to
pick-- I'm going
to go with C. I'm going to give
you a fighting chance, right?
Because we figured A
beat C for sure, right?
Because you've got a couple
of 6 and 7 beat up 3 and 4
pretty good.
Yeah, I'm going to
pick C. All right.
And now we're going to
do-- figure out which
one's more likely to win.
And we're going to
make the tree diagram.
All right?
So here's A. You've got 2,
6, and 7 are your choices.
And they're each 1/3.
And then, for mine,
I've got 3, 4, and 8.
3, 4, and 8.
And they're all 1/3 chance.
All right, so I
make my tree here.
I got squished at the
bottom, but they're all 1/3.
All right, now we're
going to see who wins,
C or A. There's nine outcomes.
Who wins this outcome?
Oh, I do.
Yeah, I get all these.
That's good.
You're in trouble already.
What happens here, though?
Who wins that?
Your 6 beats 3, 6 beats 4.
You win those.
I got you here.
Then you win 7 beats 3.
A wins.
7 beats 4, A wins.
It's tied, but, oh,
my 8 beat your 7.
All right.
So let's see here.
There's one, two, three, four,
five for me, each at 1/9.
All right, so I'm going to win.
All right?
Now, in this case, the
sample space is uniform.
Every probability is the
same for the outcomes.
They're all 1/9.
1/3 times 1/3.
All right?
So that's the case where we say
the sample space is uniform.
Don't go anywhere.
We're going to do
some more here.
The sample space is uniform
if every sample point
has the same probability.
In which case, the probability
of the sample points
would be 1 in the cardinality
of the sample space.
In this case,
there's nine points.
They each have probability 1/9.
And in this case, C beats
A with probability of 5/9.
That means I win the dollar.
All right.
So do you have some
more money in there?
In that wallet?
I'll make change for you.
So, what we're going
to do is play again.
And you've learned something
now, that C beats A.
So we play again,
you're probably
not going to want
to pick A. In fact,
C is surprisingly good there.
Now, I'll let you
wager more, if you
want, to win your dollar back.
Do you want to do
double or nothing?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So you always
get to pick second, though?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I've got to be fair here.
I'm going to let you pick first.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, you got
a couple bucks?
We'll do double or nothing.
What do you say?
I'll make change for you.
There you go.
Here's $5.
I'll change your $5.
And then we'll bet $2.
How's that?
I've actually got
a $2 bill here.
There we go.
You've got $2.
All right, double or nothing.
Will, what do you like?
You're obviously
not going to pick
A. That just got beat by C.
What do you like, B or C?
Well, one of them's
got to be best.
One of them's got
to be best here.
You've just got to figure
out which one it is.
AUDIENCE: I feel like everyone's
going to have [INAUDIBLE].
If I choose C, let me see.
That would be
[INAUDIBLE] so I guess.
PROFESSOR: I won't pick
A, that's for sure.
AUDIENCE: If you pick
B, I get one from 4,
I get two from the
8, which is four.
And you get the other five.
If I pick C and you pick A,
that means I get one from the 3,
I get one from the 4.
If I get two from the
8, you still get 5.
PROFESSOR: That's good.
You've figured out
you're screwed here.
That's very good.
All right.
So, yeah, so he's sort
of-- he's doing great.
He's figured out, because
he went through this sort
of like this method, what all
the possible outcomes were.
And he's discovered that,
no matter what he picks,
I'm going to beat him.
So let's see why
that's the case.
So let's see.
So because you figured it
out, I won't take your money
this time.
But we'll do some
more in a minute.
So say Will picked--
say he picked C.
And say that then I
will pick B. All right,
so on C, there's three choices.
3.
4, and 8.
And then, on my choice of
B, there's 1, 5, and 9.
All right, so I get 1, 5, and 9.
And now we can
see who wins here.
Well, C wins there,
loses here, loses there.
C wins here, and B
wins the next two.
And C wins these.
And B wins the tiebreaker.
So B beats C with
probability 5/9.
All right.
So you don't want to pick
A, you don't want to pick C,
you want to try a bet with B?
I mean, look, you've got B
beats C. We just showed that.
C beats A. I mean, that's a
sure bet if I ever saw one.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: What do you think?
AUDIENCE: So if I pick B and you
pick C, that means [INAUDIBLE]
[AUDIENCE CHATTER]
But if he picks A, then
I get [INAUDIBLE] Yeah,
I'd still get 4, so--
PROFESSOR: So if you pick
B, what am I going to do?
AUDIENCE: Oh, you're
going to pick A.
PROFESSOR: I'm going to pick A.
Let's see how that works out.
All right, so B has 1, 5, and 9.
A is, yeah, 2, 6, and 7.
OK, so you're going to
lose all three there.
A wins those.
A wins-- no, you win.
B wins there, but A
wins the next couple.
And then, you win
the last three.
So A wins, again,
5/9 of the time.
So how is this possible?
We've got A beats B,
beats C, beats A. All 5/9.
How is that possible?
Did we make a mistake?
Well, why isn't it possible?
Whoever said probabilities
were transitive?
Right?
I mean, you'd sort
of think there's
a best of the three die.
But for any one that
you pick, that he picks,
I can find one that's better.
And it goes in a cycle.
All right?
So you'd think picking
first, you've got a shot
to pick the best one.
But picking second
always wins this game,
if you pick the right one.
All right.
You know, since you did
good and figured that out,
I'm going to give you a
special opportunity here.
All right?
Now, I'm going to
let you go second.
All right?
So I'm going to
pick one, and I'm
going to let you pick after me.
And then we're going to bet.
There's going to be
a little twist to it.
But you want to
pick second, right?
All right, well, let me tell
you what I'm going to do.
Just to make it-- I want
to do a different analysis.
We already did these three,
so what I'm going to do
is an analysis where
we roll them twice.
Otherwise, it's the
same basic thing,
but I want to do an analysis
with more outcomes here.
We've sort of beat
this one to death.
So I'm going to go first.
And let's see, what
do I want to pick?
Hm.
Well, what should I pick,
if I'm going to do this?
I guess I'll pick B, all right?
So I'm going to pick B here.
All right.
How much do you
want to bet here?
I'm going to let you
win your money back.
I'll let you bet up to $10.
Your choice.
What do you-- what do
you want to bet here?
We've got to put some
money on the table,
make it a little interesting.
Yeah, you pick--
AUDIENCE: Do you roll a
different die or what?
PROFESSOR: No, the same ones.
The die don't change.
I'm picking B. And I'm going
to roll it a couple times.
And I'm going to
add up my score.
And then, you get to pick
whatever die you want.
I'm going to let you pick.
I mean, I'm going to let you
pick the one that beats it.
You roll yours a couple times.
And now we see which
one has the higher
sum, who's more likely to win.
AUDIENCE: So it's the sum
total, like you roll a 9 and 9
and I roll a 7 and 7.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, then I'm
going to win, because I get 18
and you got 14.
If I roll a 9 and
a 1, I get a 10.
You roll a 6 and a
7, you beat me at 13.
All right?
So which one do
you want to pick?
You could pick C. But you've got
to put the money on the table
here, whatever you want to bet.
You know, I want to give you a
chance to win your money back.
What's the probability
he's going to lose?
[LAUGHTER]
You got a T-Card?
What've you got in there?
Ah, I'll take the
[INAUDIBLE] card.
What's that worth?
Ah, it's worth a few bucks here.
All right, so I'm picking
B. Which are you picking?
I've really got his
head messed up now.
AUDIENCE: There's
$4 on the table.
Take that and run.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, really.
We already saw-- I'll
give you a hint here.
A beats B. 5/9 of the time,
A comes up higher than B.
So if we roll them
twice, your odds
got even better that
A beats B. All right,
so Will goes with A. Will,
that was a big mistake.
All right.
How can it be a mistake?
A beats B 5/9 of the time.
Now what we're going to do
is make the decision tree.
If we roll B twice,
if we roll A twice.
All right.
Let's see what happens.
This is a nasty
one to write down.
In fact, you'll start
seeing this when you
do these tree method things.
Sometimes the trees
get a little hairy,
so we've got to sort of
approximate it a little bit.
So here's B, right?
I got 1, 5, and 9
for my first roll.
And then I got 1, 5, and
9 for my second roll.
And I add these up.
See, if you read the notes
ahead, sometimes that helps.
6-- here are my outcomes.
These are the numbers
I'm going to get.
These are my nine values.
Your nine values,
you got 2, 6, and 7.
Then each 2, 6, and 7 again.
So we add those up, you got 4,
8, 9, 8, 12, 13, 9, 13, and 14.
And now, we have
each one of these
against each one of these.
Because there's 81 outcomes.
I got four levels to the tree.
And rather than draw four
levels of this [INAUDIBLE] tree
to get 81 outcomes,
you're going to say
that each one of
these corresponds
to this tree, all right,
that has nine leaves.
And now we can just count
up how many times I win.
Well, 2 got nothing.
That's a 0.
Let's see how many times 6 wins.
One-- one time.
10-- one, two,
three, four, five.
All right, we've got that.
6 wins, we already
decided, once.
10, we decided already,
wins five times.
14 wins one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight, and ties once.
Tie-- one.
10, we already got was five.
14, we already got,
was eight and a tie.
And finally, I get
18 wins every time.
Let's add this up.
I got 17, 22, 30,
35, 36, 41, 42 times
plus half the ties out of 81.
How much money's on
this [INAUDIBLE] card?
Ah, smart guy.
How did this happen?
A is more likely to
beat B, higher than B.
But you roll them
twice, and it's
less likely to be
as large on the sum?
Well, why not?
It's just our intuition's
all screwed up.
But the math is straightforward.
In fact, an amazing
thing happens.
If you roll them twice,
they reverse completely.
A is worse than B, is worse
than C, is worse than A
if you roll them twice.
If you roll them three times,
something else happens.
In fact, it was known
for a long time,
this phenomenon
happens with one roll.
And when I was making lecture
notes a few years ago,
I noticed they reverse
with two rolls.
And then we did a class
project to discover
what happens with k rolls.
And it turns out that you can
get every possible combination.
You know, on some
number of rolls,
A beats both B and C and B
beats C. Other number of rolls,
A beats them both and C beats B.
And then, motivated by
that, some researchers
out in San Diego showed
that there's arbitrarily
strange dice, now, not
with just three sides,
but with more sides.
Such that, for any tournaments--
remember a tournament
from graph theory,
where everybody beats,
you know, between a pair of
players, one player wins.
You can make the relation
for any tournament
show up for a
particular set of dice
by rolling a certain
number of times.
All right, which is
just really fascinating
that you can prove that.
So these dice can
get arbitrarily weird
in terms of which die is
likely to come up and be
better than another die.
All right, that's it for today.
Let me give you your
money back here.
And I've got a gift
certificate you can
have for being a good sport.
Here you go.
How much money did I take here?
AUDIENCE: I think only like $2.
PROFESSOR: $2?
All right, there you go.
Very good.
Thanks.
So we'll do a lot more examples
over the next week or two.